it's not in your back hmm
let's do it here we go all right five
four three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are featuring John Bob lock today
what's up
fantastic it's filled to be here it's
good to see you Alan thank you
appreciate it
we are gonna be unpacking some crucial
conversation I'm excited for it you have
got a cool background and you're really
focused on something that I think is
crucial for society to really button
into get ready for and and bring that
impact the world so let's let's jump
into it so like what what led you into
this this this decision to want to bring
more impact and decentralization and
care for the population people through
sustainability and through impacted how
did this how did you become who you are
there's a lot of questions in there Alan
so let me start off by saying I'm I'm
more excited now about the prospects for
Humanity and the time that we live in
this is one of the most exciting times
that I've experienced in in a long time
if not ever in my lifetime and if you'd
asked me five years ago you would have
gotten a very different answer for me I
will I had reached a point of depression
and up and that the human species was
really heading off a cliff and we didn't
have the tools to save what could be
taking the planet down of course that
have no return for either our
survivability as a species if not taking
a number of the other species along with
us in a failed experiment and I think we
need to pause there because let's stay
with that feeling for a little bit we
don't talk about that feeling enough on
the show what was going on for you that
you were observing the world around you
and feeling what was going on and you
just felt very pessimistic
talk to us about that well it's a that's
thank you for raising it that way the
let's use climate change as a way as a
lens to kind of get into this question
and it's something that I've been
working on for thirty years or so and we
can talk about more because it does it
ties back to this question about what
what's optimistic today and what's
driving me and climate ISM is a
significant theme the the linear the the
numbers that I was looking at population
of the human species the rate at which
our society and our economies were
emitting the the the heat trapping gases
the speed at which we as a society or
such group of societies were or were not
accepting what was happening and making
changes to our emission of those gases
if you just started to linearly plot out
those lines we were it was the it really
looked like there was no other other
possibility except we would have a world
that would be at least three if not four
degrees Celsius warmer and when we look
at the what that would look like in
terms of a livable planet it's the
planet that very few of us would
actually survive in right we'd have to
almost create bubbles and live within
bubbles and I have children they would
be at the at the their generation would
begin to really experience that world
and that's something that that I've been
trying to avoid and I'm you know there's
millions of me out there work you know
fighting this fight that that have a
sense but there was that pessimism was
driven by a linear sense of how things
would move and what is ring is it's
especially important to leave the world
in a place that's better than when we
were birthed into it not in a place
where the children have to work much
harder to fix the problems that we left
them
I used to have a bar that said leave it
better but the bar lately has been just
make it livable mm-hmm right we're at
the question now our generation and
every generation faces a major task and
world war two of the generations faced a
major task of keeping them you know
keeping together the societies which
were based upon democracy versus Tollett
Arianism and you know our generation we
have a great task of can we actually
leave a livable planet not one that's
better at this point the question is is
it livable yep right and crazy that
that's even the question so to me that's
that that's a it's a challenge and it's
and but when you didn't feel you had
tools and I felt and I'd spent 25 years
using the tools of government and policy
and regulation and then nonprofits and
activism then moved into technology and
moved into capitalism and moving finance
so my so my journey started in the in
the 1980s and I was in the US Senate as
an a at a young age and this is the cult
page so you know so you know the game a
little bit you know you know the Nazi
but I was in the legislature in South
Dakota
Oh fantastic on being a page it's it's
very heady to feel as if you're you're a
part of the creation of history yeah
that's a good way to put it
it almost inevitably gets at your ego
and you gotta like figure out absolutely
gets your ego you gotta like you've got
to figure out how to quell it but
politicians are meditating and taking
psychedelics and practicing the oneness
they're there a few there so there are a
few things I think would be is lighten
politicians right but they're a rare
breed so this is back in the 80s and and
so the Cold War was in full swing
Gorbachev wasn't quite yet coming to
power so we didn't have a tempering of
the the tension between
really they know there was a fight about
whose system of governing humans was
better was it free market and democracy
which we were standing for or was it
socialism or some form of communism
which the Soviet structure was was
proposing and I I became involved in a
very interesting way I was an intern I
started as an intern and I started to
work for a senator from New Hampshire
who took it upon himself to to really go
after the Soviet Union and make life
difficult for them because he was he was
a hawk and so so at the time a hard hard
right Republican I would work with folks
like Jesse Helms and Orrin Hatch and you
know the the more hawkish side to make
Soviet expansion more painful for Moscow
and more expensive I happen to be a rock
climber I really want to ask how you
helped make it more painful yes so I'm
getting there so I used to be a rock
climber and the senator heard through
the through the staff that I knew how to
Mountaineer and climb rocks and so he
invited me up into his little office
senators have big offices where it's
more formal when you meet the
constituents and you have meetings but
they have private offices that are in
the Capitol dome yeah where you would
have your more discreet meetings right
and his was he was a junior senator so
his was higher up the more power you
have the closer you are to the floor and
the the not so he had an office it was
actually in the dome so it had a curved
roof and you could get three or four
people in there and it had a desk in a
couple couches and stuff so getting
called into a room like that
one year I think it was 19 or something
it was a little intimidating and I was
alone and they didn't know quite know
what's going to happen so I was excited
but a little nervous and he lays a map
out on the table and it didn't have any
markings it was just the top topo map
and he said could you get me over this
and it turned out to it was a map of the
afghanistan-pakistan area and it was the
mountain range that ran from between
Pakistan and Afghanistan
and I looked at it and you know they're
they're from a mountaineering standpoint
they're difficult but they're not like
Everest or they're not it's not you know
it's more intense hiking with with a
little bit right I was like sure
absolutely that's how I became involved
with what became a good ten year run of
which eventually became the the staff
director of the Congressional Task Force
on Afghanistan moving billions and
weapons that started in Afghanistan then
Angola then Nicaragua and basically we
set out a strategy that was called the
bleeders if we could take down it was a
strategy to shorten and and perhaps end
the Cold War much quicker if we could
take down the economic equivalent of one
MIG a week marek a MIG MIG a MIG which
was a Soviet fighter which is like an
f16 if we could take down the equivalent
of a soviet equivalent of an f-16 or
what would be about the same cost per
movement of weapons and aircraft just
take lightly destroy this like destroy
them like a missile yeah if we could
destroy a MIG a week then the Soviet
military industrial complex wouldn't
would cease to be able to provide
weapons and food to the Soviet Union and
they will start to collapse okay so you
were analyzing the topographical nature
of G of geography and then saying how do
we prevent the proliferation of weaponry
to places that are promoting socialism
communism but also trying to take no no
no we we took the other route it was a
let's arm every place where the Soviet
Union was outside of its borders we
would arm a resistance with as many
weapons as we could put it in their
hands to to destroy their military
complex right where they're trying to
expand threat were arming the insurgency
against their expansion and then trying
to take down those MiG's great
so that was them so does it Afghanistan
was to start and then Angola was were
kit and then Nicaragua with the Contras
battleground Wow and we moved a we moved
a lot of weapons and it was you know
somewhat it was somewhat successful geez
and it's so crazy and how do you
identify people that actually want to be
a part of the insurgency how do you
build an alliance that is so difficult
to figure out how to do well yes it is
difficult to figure out who you can
trust and who you can't trust it turns
out that in the F there's the the
unintended consequences of the decisions
that you make you don't really know
until later it turns out the the
training camps that we built in the
Pakistan border trained Osama bin Laden
yeah Jesus Christ because at the time
given what we were attempting to do you
know the the the lens and the
decision-making lens at the time was
armed and trained those who could go in
and inflict damage upon the Soviet Union
and Soviet forces what they do 10 years
down the line five years down the line
you know we would think about it but
should just move it on the fly you're
making decisions that were based upon
the intent then you're trying to put in
play in you know structures that would
relate the long-term damage but that's
very hard to do the weapon that that was
the really the the conversation was
around do we give the Stinger missile to
do we let this thing or missile into the
hands of those that we can't control we
ultimately decided to do it and those of
us that were party and that Stinger
missile was a was brilliant weapon it's
a handheld very small heat-seeking
heat-seeking ground-to-air missile yeah
and there the stinger I actually
remember II intelligence I've been from
call of duty I think it was the game
that I used to play like that used to be
a ground-to-air rocket launcher that
could seek the the plane and take it
down correct
so you could or you could put this in
the hands of people all throughout the
whole mountain range of of
the battle and without very expensive
you know troops and everything else that
usually would go along with this and we
changed the course of the war because we
started taking down their MiG's Wow
wow that is an easy that's how but we
were we were pretty convinced that they
would end up on the black market and I
would take down a commercial 747 yeah
and all of us would have blood on our
hands yeah
right so we did a bunch of things to try
to make sure that didn't happen
I think you had to have people working
within them making sure they're well
they weren't we tried to track them and
we try to train them when you had to
know but we were conservatives you can't
you can't trust the system there's
always going to be a break death row we
we were convinced that the risk of
losing civilians innocent civilians in a
747 was worth the the arming to take
down we had to make that gamble right
and and to come to terms with that as a
decision-making point it end up not
happening what happened in a bizarre
twist of history was we trained Osama
bin Laden their training camps he used
the plane as the weapon in 9/11 not
shooting down a plane he took used the
plane the plane became the weapon not
the vehicle and we weren't thinking
about that not at all Wow
so for those of us that were in that it
they were in in the beginning game when
9/11 happened it was the most
upside-down moment yeah
because we've all sort of flashed
exactly what had happened we trained
them we armed them I'm getting up this
is a little this is a cul-de-sac
this is taller this is a total called
sector what were suppose you're like
event of your life it's so interesting
it's so really important anyway that the
you you think I mean the lesson here is
that you know you can you can think
things out and you can try to put in
place protections and steps to put
boundaries around what you're trying to
do
but history has a way and humanity in
the course of events have a weight of
just the unexpected happens and and that
process to me was the 9/11 was so
unexpected that was a twist that was
about 20 years or so that led up to that
to that 9/11 moment yeah so let's say an
85 Osama bin Laden starts showing up in
about 1985 okay about 16 years yeah Wow
yeah you're right that twist of events
and what happened this is crazy
most people would never view it this way
but the creativity that was there of
figuring out to use the plane correct so
anyway so in so in the Senate so I'm in
the Senate and this gets back to more
why is this an important time to be
alive and what's happening the the and
it was all through the government right
this is all government work and what
Department of the government is I was in
the Senate so the Senate has
considerable Foreign Affairs power
because of the Constitution it has
seated a lot of that power to the
executive branch and then particularly
since Vietnam in a military decision
worse the Senate is supposed to have to
say whether we go to war or not but
we're we're engaged in quote-unquote war
all the time now we just never declare
it so there's a breakdown in the in the
checks and balances yeah that the
Constitution intended and that's a whole
other conversation but the War Powers
Act all that foreign policy still exists
today from like observing areas of the
world that are trying to have radical
authoritarian military creating lots of
power overthrows and all the stuff and
just being able to prevent innocent
civilians across the world from debt
from death and from the harm is
constantly happening although it's not
in a state of war okay so to say at the
same time that were they were launching
this bleeder strategy right bleed this
the union yeah get the code word stop
there the Al Gore is ramping up the
first hearings in the Senate on climate
change which I help staff ask so here's
this data set Wow about carbon and
temperature and we're just at the big
you know we're about four or five years
into maybe maybe eight years there's the
science the science are beginning to get
enough data going you know we've kind of
had this correlation of greenhouse gases
and this trend that says that that looks
pretty interesting the data look matches
pretty much to the Industrial Revolution
and the burning of fossil fuels to a
heating of the planet that is that
doesn't correlate with natural cycles
right that there's there's a there's an
increase that's that the natural cycles
are it's beyond the natural cycle so the
this looks to be human driven the same
time the bleeding's going one of the
Soviets so I was doing both at the same
time right so I'm asking the scientists
the scientific community what do you
need to start to address the climate
crisis and they say we have no budget
because all of the budget is driven by
Cold War driven priorities yeah nuclear
space weapons rights Reagan and Star
Wars if you remember his Star Wars thing
and so the the the the big chunks of
budget that were that were needed that
the scientists would need to start to
actually dig into climate because it was
new science was wasn't and so the best
minds and the best scientific budgets
were all going to the Cold War so I was
like well we got so we have to stop the
Cold War to free up the think the the
resources in the thinking to start to
address what to me it became really
clear it's not the human to human
conflict about whether my system in your
system where their free market versus
communism is better that ceased to
become the real threat to humanity when
the climate scenario emerged to me it
was like well it's whether we even have
a livable planet begin with yeah that's
a key consciousness shifting becomes the
quest
to address yeah but now we have to get
rid of this first one yeah in order to
get to the second one yeah yeah yeah
having both those things happen
simultaneously it kind of puts it's so
funny because it put it put the the war
for nationalism into a could it could
what could potentially put the war for
nationalism on the backburner
oh well probably having a planet where
our kids can even live on that planet
and so that interestingly enough ended
up kind of being like wow so now we have
the war on two fronts of becoming a
sustainable planet but also at the same
time trying to provide as much democracy
across the planet as possible okay so
have we packed away that called the war
cul-de-sac yeah and now we can move on
so let's hope we end it right it ended
suddenly because we're taking down one a
week one make a week roughly and okay so
we're slowly bled that out the fighters
planes there's a number of reasons why
the number reason this was this helped
helped collapse it okay so then it
collapses and the in 91 and then there
is this
I wanted Al Gore do the first eight 1986
I believe was 1985 1986 first real kind
of a he brought it into the national
consciousness because he was working
with a scientist directly been working
with a scientist that was a mentor of
his great so and he he did a really good
job of helping bring it up yes right
around mid eighties okay
so then so then one the Soviet problem
takes it D regulates a bit and then we
had an environmental crisis mental
crisis gets more attention in the 90s
starts to right
Coleman it there's there was a there was
a period of increasing awareness that we
as a species at a global level have to
start to work together correct
that that manifested itself in the 1992
Earth Summit the first Earth Summit in
Rio de Janeiro
it was the largest gathering of
countries and heads of state ever that
said okay we're all in that we all live
on the same planet yep we need to start
to work together to address at a
planetary scale the ecosystem first that
was the first and biggest though that
and so it was important because of that
first step there somewhat still goes on
today every year every 20 or so there's
a but there's lots and lots of Oh
initiatives moving forward yeah right
and there's the climate ones in Paris I
mean that well typically we were that we
react to a crisis when the crisis is
full-blown that and then one of the
reasons we're not reacting to climate is
because it's it's it's playing out and
so it's such slow motion for from our
perception of time that it's hard for us
to grasp the crisis because it's playing
itself out very very slowly right but
things that happen suddenly we haven't
were much better equipped to address so
in the late 90s there was something
called acid rain begin to happen and
this was basically the smokestacks if
you were if you lived in the Northeast
you knew all about this so the the coal
burning power plants in the Midwest were
emitting basically unfiltered nitrous
oxide and and NOx and Sox it was called
to two major pollutants they would go up
they would hit the the lower-level
atmosphere and they would move across
the United States and the the air stream
would move them to New England and
Canada and they were basically dumping
these two chemicals and and coal soot
into New England and Canada and it
basically it was a it was Lily rain
which was acidic and it was killing off
the lakes and the trees and the fish at
pretty wide scale so there was also
there was this crisis right what do we
do and people were getting you know as
they do upset and demanding action so I
was still in the Senate and we were
looking for solutions and we came up
with an untried process called
cap-and-trade what year was this
in 88 89 89 98 89 90
roughly cap-and-trade if you look at it
looks like token ah mcc's yeah and it
looks like it it looks very similar to a
cryptocurrency and it looks very similar
to what we're seeing a lot some of the
models were now seeing in blockchain the
notion was to create a marketplace where
you use market incentives to drive a
certain kind of action yep and so we set
up we didn't know what's gonna work it
was a total it was an experiment it
ended up working quite well it solved
the acid grading problem and probably 10
years quicker than we thought at much
less cost than we thought Dorris so only
a certain amount of pollution credits
that the energy companies got so there
was a person issue of a basically a
certain number of credits those critics
represented the the right to to pollute
NOx and Sox into the atmosphere the over
time those credits would start to be
removed there would be less and less of
them so the first year there'd be I
can't run the exact number let's say
there'd be a million credits then the
next year they'd be 900 thousand eight
hundred thousand seven one thousand if
you wanted to keep polluting you want to
be put in do you have a higher the
credit credits from Ora to give you the
right to pollute and so you'd basically
push people to sustainable sort right so
it's an it drove the government made a
decision we're gonna create a
marketplace but we're not going to
determine how you get there we're not
gonna choose technology winners yeah
we're not gonna dictate the way that you
do it we're gonna let the marketplace
and and human ingenuity and and
capitalism at its best which is there's
some boundaries right that protect the
Commons which is what this was hey we're
doing this to protect and value the
comments that come to air we breathe and
the fish in the trees and then we
determine that there was have value by
doing this and it worked quite well so
now and I held on to that notion going
okay it worked here
and the farther along we got ever since
then for the last 25 years we have been
really unable to address the greater
climate problem right because we we
haven't been able to get the market
doesn't have the boundaries and the
incentives yet within which to actually
address and turn the problem into profit
so as black chain starts to emerge I
looked at it for a couple years inlet it
was like okay it's interesting then I
started seeing the speculation go okay
it's interesting you could make some
profit but it was when I started to
really look at black chain as through
the lens of can it solve society's pit
solve what we have not been able to
solve which is how to value and
incentivize the Commons that I got so
excited so that brings us to today I
love it wait let's and we will get to
the bureau right now we'll get there I
want to stay on I want to stay here for
a second so this is probably one of like
the coolest ways that my mind has
recently been expanded thanks to you is
that cap-and-trade was actually a very
interesting way that the government did
not dictate the ingenuity but they said
that hey we do need a transition over
time so we're gonna make a mark we're
gonna we're gonna create a system kind
of like token omics is and that that
cap-and-trade slowly led companies away
from the crazy environmental pollution I
was going on in the Northeast and in
Canada that sounds horrible and it led
them slowly over time towards being like
we can't afford all these crazy credits
that we need for pollution so let's um
let's make the transition to alternative
energy and then that was kind of the so
went from gore to the cap-and-trade to
alternative energy and yeah and
cap-and-trade is a Republican concept
it's a it was Republican promoted it was
a republic
bill it was Republican crafted and it
was driven by the Republican arguments
of don't fetter human creativity yeah
create some rules and a marketplace
don't use regulation or stimulate
ingenuity yeah and it was all
Republicans thing yeah I wonder what
policies if we did if we implemented
that exact there's some similar sort of
mentality and systems thinking to today
what would happen to certain areas of
the world that we need to work on and
improve with the sort of mentality of
like a cap and trade don't hinder an
ingenuity but create a market like that
that's so interesting that it was all
like Republican driven Wow at the time
the Republic rat said find them right
just come in and set up fines and
regulate that you you will you have to
cease those emissions and and if you
don't you will find you right that was
there wow that was the that was the
heavy hand of regulation fine right yeah
there was no carrot it's just stick
right and so it was it was the it was a
Republican response to come up with with
the camera the market yeah the market so
the house so interests off it yeah the
care the carrot the carrot became a
cap-and-trade hanging over their heads
and they were like okay that's how we
have to transition okay so it's so
interesting where that can be applied
today to make the world better I don't
know and I really want to figure that
out hanging that carrot and seeing how
people transition okay so how about
maybe like the education sector okay so
so okay so now as you see you know
you're initially seeing the technology
of blockchain a decentralization a
decentralized digital ledger as you're
seeing this come into into the world and
token aa mcc's come into the world you
make that link and you're like ha
I now feel more optimistic about
providing empowering all people to be a
part of building the future the the
optimism is is is it comes from tech now
the digitization is empowers people
digitation broadly right so the move
from analog to digital
and the move from what came before to
analog each of those steps gives more
information quicker to more people and
did and going digital as they could be
not just a supernova mm-hmm
the blockchain creates a simultaneously
a way for everybody to see data whatever
that data is to trust the authenticity
of that data and once you can once you
can see it and you can trust it you have
you have the underpinnings of market now
you can lay on top of you lay on top of
that governance that is attached to the
trust and with those three things what
you require government to do you no
longer require the government to do and
governments around the world have been
exceedingly slow in their be their
capacity to address the tragedy of the
Commons
so that this tool that is now empowering
individuals and groups of individuals to
create marketplaces without the
government having to set up a rule the
cap-and-trade required the government to
come in and establish a system within
which the the the economy would play
right how that system functioned is very
similar to what happens within a
blockchain and a token Amish structure
but you but you needed the government to
set the rules up now we don't need the
government we can create marketplaces to
address the Commons without waiting for
the political census consent its
political consensus to be there because
we're not getting it or it's not coming
fast enough in my in my view given given
the the rate at which the world is
changing so climate so that is
fundamental shift right of market the
empowering and creating a marketplace
without a government setting up the
rules yeah I mean that was the euro now
we can do this right okay we're and it's
not about lobbying governments and and
and right we still do that work but we
can actually we can now move forward and
start to execute and create these
marketplaces and we can give carbon
value and we can give some of these
other things that we've been known as
externalities putting into the
environment without a cost and then
society has to somehow figure out how to
pay for that externality we can turn
around and say that externality now is a
commodity that we can put value upon and
now we can address it so okay we're
observing all these different markets
that are proliferating and now we can
leverage technologies like blockchain
and cryptocurrencies to address some of
the biggest issues that are going on in
those markets and in those sectors by
creating some sort of incentivization
strategies for people maybe leveraging
token ah mcc's like a cap-and-trade
system in those different markets say
yeah that's cool correct yeah that's
really exciting how it can actually be
applied to I would have
the excuse me sorry the history that
that initially cap-and-trade was a big
role in tapering us away from fossil
fuels to alternative sources of energy
that puzzle that happened you said like
86 tell like mid-90s was that kind of
like that 10-year window there's
something there okay
lately that that that I would not have
related to 2018 and toconao mix and
blockchain in the way that we can
augment these markets through similar
kind of cap-and-trade process to foster
creativity I would have never made that
connection until you brought it into my
life and I hope that that really
resonates with other people yeah yeah
it's beautiful hey listen we're all
standing upon the shoulders of giants
that has come before us and and these
these ideas are these ideas or
iterations of ideas that have been
moving through through our species for
often for long periods of time it's its
timing and the you know we needed enough
people to have enough bandwidth and
connectivity and enough computing power
distributed enough to even think about
having distributed governance and
distributed markets right I mean there's
the it's happening when it when it when
it needs to write this evolution so but
the fact that's why I'm so excited now
is that this this set of tools it can
its it can help us break free of this
this this resistance that has been in
that that I think a lot of us are
feeling that the government's are not
moving to it to govern the world within
which we're evolving fast enough and so
there's a there's a there's a tension
right and so black chain allows us to
release that tension in a productive way
to actually execute
I like that blockchain is relieving that
tension for us so why don't you give us
a couple of the key areas that you're
thinking this is most applicable in and
then because is would you say this is
what you're doing well as the chief
strategic officer at the bureau yes so
let me tell you so how this how I'm
manifesting this now is I'm really
excited to be working with a it's a
great team and we're building something
called Bureau it's about nine months old
it's moving very very quickly but we saw
an opportunity to - we saw that
blockchain can be used for many many to
adjust many problems in the world
and to create many different
marketplaces and what has the sweet
sense of what can we do to add value how
can we help move this forward and so
what we came up with says well let's
build a platform that is solely focused
on helping other entrepreneurs and other
projects and other companies that use
blockchain for the greater good or
impact or addressing climate or whatever
term you want to use but that are using
black team to address intractable
problems that our species faces let's
build a platform that helps those
projects go from idea to execution much
quicker yep let's accelerate that
process so we've built the Bureau is is
100% focused on helping those projects
go from idea to getting out in the
market so we're building we have an
engineering team that people can
leverage we have a marketing team that
people can leverage a token Amish team
that people can leverage you know a
business team that people can leverage
and and then we'll be adding on to that
later on a fund that we're going to be
raising and then we'll be able to add a
you know significant amounts of of at
risk capital to get those those projects
moving are you thinking about so it's so
it's it's about volume are you thinking
about it as a
both as a consultancy then and also as
an incubator to actually foster the
cohort and and as a and as a an investor
in a partner yeah correct so then you
would do something similar to the seed
investment for equity in their token or
in whatever it is and then great well
we'll help we'll help the founders form
a team what we're gonna do a whole bunch
of steps if needed will help the
founders form the team leverage our our
technology and development team thing so
that their technology moves faster so
that you know so they don't have to go
and hire everybody all at once they can
leverage what we have to get that idea
moving quicker get out into the market
by leveraging our marketing team get at
in the market and so they can grow
organically but much quicker because
you're leveraging our resources to be
that springboard and the Bureau is kind
of what we were what we were talking
about as we were finishing off the the
cap and trade conversation moving into
how that can be applied in token ah
mcc's the bureau is kind of the
manifestation of how do we address all
these different markets potentially with
token ah mcc's right okay so what are
some of the organizations that are
already using the consultancy of the
bureau if we can talk about them well
we're having come out publicly with a
lot of it I'll tell you some of the
areas so the power sector the
electricity sector in particular is one
where we're black chain the black chain
can can bring significant improvements I
mean we have an electrical grid that
really it's a marvel of human ingenuity
when you look at the complexity and the
scale at which we move electrons around
it's really quite stunning it's insane
we have a close friend
her name's Miriam she's a patron and she
totally teaches us about the way that
energy is moved and bought and sold and
it is crazy it supplies power for
Humanity and we demand we demand and
expect 99.999% up
100% if we saw three if you flick on the
switch or if you open the faucet and in
the water it's not coming out or the
electricity is not coming in you're
freaking out because you really really
expect it and in hopefully like
California recently heard this as well
California has much cleaner energy than
New York does correct correct that the
electrical grid the the the liquid fuel
system is and that whole infrastructure
that's that's different right but the
electron grid the electrical grid it's
really quite a marvel
but it's 19th early 20th century
architecture right and we've leaped and
what we need now is is is not what we
built then let's hear your solution
while you're working
well it's quite it's quick it's really
it looks much like the Internet really
it's a the internet functions because it
itself is decentralized to a great
degree you have you if we had the
internet would not function with so many
singular points of of intelligence being
so concentrated and then everybody
having to figure out a way to connect to
those singular points of intelligence
its distributed right it's distributed
all it's it's it's the distributed model
which is in the blockchain is another
take on that same model it's and it
mirrors nature and the way that nature
operates which is it's it's a very
highly distributed complex inter wolven
system it's not a centralized command
control system totally when one of the
trees has an excess of of carbon then
it's been sequestering and it has a root
system underground there's a whole
conversation that's going on between the
smaller trees and the larger trees and
the mycelium but I think you're I'm glad
you're up on that that that that the
awakening to what has been happening
right because science is finally
catching up and it is not it is not
survival of the fittest that that is the
rule it is
it is a highly cooperative intelligent
system yeah and those but we've had this
note we've had this notion of it's
survival of the fittest that everything
everyone's competing out there in a
forest or an ecosystem is one of
competition what's it's it's totally
different
it is complete cooperation and a network
and it's a distributed intelligent
network so the electrical grid is going
it will go the same way that the
internet went to do that it will be a
suit so that means that power is is
produced locally and consumed as locally
to its production as you possibly can
get and it will have multiple types of
production and the web interlinking
those those will will be much more like
the mycelium and the mushroom in the in
underneath the soil then it will be this
command control power plant with big
lines really across yep oh that sounds
so great but the blockchain is required
now to create the marketplaces that
allows these micro grids to flourish
within themselves yeah for intelligence
and billing and owner and ownership
it's the ownership structure yeah you
have to you have to break the ownership
structure down you're the right right
now a lot of what goes on is this this
storage of energy and then the
distribution and selling that stored
energy to other energy companies that
then distribute it to to the people that
are in their homes using it
that's our 15 minute timer thank you Ron
and we go John did you attend the acting
and time on energy policy consortium at
Harvard about 10 years ago I did not
okay okay never mind back to the show
I just videotape to die and you would
talk about cap and trade and they were
discussing all these things ten years
ago back in
at that yeah oh thank you though Ron
yeah john holdren was there john dodge
will see a whole bunch of even prominent
players and asking these difficult
questions I think I remember seeing that
video on your website that you had that
yeah you did
okay sorry no no that are you Bobby
that's a good segue we're because
because I think we'll talk about that
afterward okay so check so check this
out so rather than having it be this the
the the in the initial source of energy
will then store it and then sell it and
distribute it to a local organization
that will then distribute it further to
the homes and all that stuff now we're
adding a more of that like route network
the nature network to potentially get
all of the sources of energy but in a
sustainable way as close to the location
that it's being distributed to as
possible on in a way that's a digital
ledger that's decentralized very easy to
to see and tap into and that's kind of
one of the first big projects that is
being worked on at the bureau we're
working on on some energy projects for
sure we're give you some other really
exciting use cases I might I'm gonna
stack a few other nonlinear technologies
like the blockchain
on top of this to make it even more
interesting so if you think about one of
the ways that we can address the climate
issue is by planting the trees are one
of the one of the most brilliant natural
creations out there right they they
produced the air we breathe and they
take carbon out and they create shade
and they create water and I mean they
the utility of a tree for for life
itself is pretty high up there very very
high utility of a tree and I do want to
make sure that we all know that trees
are 30 percent ish of of oxygen we get
about 70% from plankton from thank you I
didn't know that yeah it's crazy
seventy percent like different plankton
from the ocean yeah that's it's nuts -
thank you plankton yeah thank you
plankton yeah no kidding right yeah
continue with trees hi
we don't get shade free plankton they
don't give us brute plankton don't think
samples yeah we don't have enough trees
and we've been we've been cutting down
trees for you know industrial uses and
and as a resource if we planted more
trees it Sam it's good for it there's
there's very few who would say that
planting a lot more cheese was not it's
not a good thing the way in which we've
been planting trees however it's it's
it's not particularly cost-effective
because you usually have to take a human
and you take humans out you have to grow
them and then you to give humans sets
little seedlings and the humans go out
and they have to plant them well there's
a way now to use robotics and artificial
intelligence and Big Data and the
blockchain wrap it all into one and
basically address tree planting at a
whole different scale and a whole
different cost structure I'm just
imagining this massive combine that goes
and plants trees and like robotically
moves across the the field and just
plants salads but it's even more
efficient is that it's drones and pretty
good you know decent drones and the
drones have seedlings that are in a pod
so that so that so it has a little bit
of soil and and the roots are sitting in
a pot yeah the drone the where's you're
gonna plant has all been mapped out by
soil and and and water at all it so you
know what you're working with you're
you're controlling it robotically the
ownership of the project is through the
blockchain so that so that it could be
fractionalized so that you're not
requiring some big government to pay the
cost upfront you're distributing that
cost out and then the the monitoring et
cetera and the governance about what
happens to tree over the lifetime the
blockchain is taking care of the the
financing and the governance and the
consensus components to this the
robotics are now taking care of the
delivery of the of what you're doing and
the basically the drone flies overhead
and shoots these trees and they shoot
shoot them with enough velocity that
they go into the soil and the capsule
breaks open and they're so now you don't
have a human
yeah walking going bump bump a bump you
basically have a drone that shooting
trees so fast as it's flying over it's
like a machine gun with trees going down
right little seedlings that you can for
10 million dollars I want make sure I
get this somewhat right but 10 million
dollars
well it allows you to plant I think a
billion trees mm-hmm now that's a that's
a 100x
cost reduction oh sweet that's from from
yeah that's a major cost reduction so we
can base so now you can you can think
about this is why I get excited because
if you just linearly look at the numbers
of where we are with climate change and
how we used to using older techniques to
address the problem that linear run of
cost versus time it didn't make sense
but these nonlinear leaps of these
technologies like robotics and
artificial intelligence and blockchain
with its piece we can we have the
capacity to terraform right yeah in a
way that is cost-effective and maybe
just in time to stave off that that
temperature curve so that we can bring
it back down and keep a livable planet
yep that was the full circle all the way
back to the beginning with what we were
discussing and how it was going up and
up and up and then now how the new
technologies that were now seeing are
gonna help us Plateau and then go back
down and it's an increase in creativity
and innovation and technology and a
decrease in pollution and a decrease in
an increase in democratization of of the
future and in leaving a livable world
for our kids okay before we run out of
time let's ask you a couple quick
simulation questions you touched on this
as we were going through it our
conversation which was the the notion of
of this individual tribalism
individualism and tribalism versus the
complete collective cohesion that we see
in nature in these underground networks
of communication as well as above-ground
networks of communication I'm less of
the Darwinian sort of best
the genetic fitness winning versus the
the collective idea the collective
collaboration idea so this question we
asked on the show a lot is what do we do
moving forward in terms of globalisation
in terms of wealth and equality Ronnie
there's something playing in the back I
don't know what it is
there's just something playing in the
back I don't know what it is but what do
we do moving forward in terms of
globalization wealth inequality how do
we how do we work together across these
borders and how do we address the
increase in wealth inequality that's
currently occurring even though the
bottom is still coming up how do we
bring them up faster so that way we can
have less of a gap where it feels like
it's either the rich or the poor I this
is gonna sound awfully simplistic but
I've people look to government for
leadership and expects our governments
to be ahead to be addressing these
issues and they and they try to to use
government I so and when you when you
expect government to lead then you get
frustrated when it doesn't and you get
you get so there's a distant and then
you get disempowered and you say well I
you know the government's not doing this
so so what can we do I think there's a
misnomer here about and if you and that
expectation government was established
within human society to adjudicate
conflict to set some rules so that we we
could live harmoniously together it
wasn't and then and and and then to
eventually to help protect us from from
external threats but it wasn't set up to
lead it's not a leading it wasn't a
leadership mechanism it was a conflict
resolution mechanism
so the problems that you're all talking
that that you that you've raised and
there's a number of them right waiting
for governments are looking at and
putting your energy around getting the
government to do something to me is is
that energy is better spent actually
saying how can I help solve the problem
what can I do to create a marketplace
what's what product can I create how can
I use and work with others to actually
go after this and not wait totally for
government to to solve it private sector
leadership and creativity innovation
what have to be private sector it's just
in personal personal responsibility and
act on it and not not say that this is
I'm gonna wait for somebody else yeah
okay so let's run you through do you do
you think we're alone in the cosmos no
do you think there are advanced
civilizations roaming the cosmos I don't
know but I was really intrigued and
heartened to see there was a scientific
paper that came out two or three weeks
ago about octopuses and octopus DNA is
so different from any other DNA that is
on the planet and it just in and
according to the this research it just
appeared quite suddenly like if there
was no natural evolution of that DNA
strand that is unlike every other
species it just appeared quickly in in
the biosphere they're not as old as
shark sharks are like four hundred
million years it was 150 million years
ago or so that the octopus all of a
sudden like boom here's a whole
different DNA structure and so the
notion that their eggs
there's here's one that the theory being
further in this paper was that their
octopus eggs were basically on some
celestial body and because they're in
space to basically cry cryogenically
frozen and so and then hit the planet
warmed up and
there they were so they came from
someplace else they're aliens we can't
eat them I made a decision a long time
ago like I and I didn't know why that I
wouldn't eat octopus right but that was
like of course because they are unlike
there they are unlike any any other
species for a whole bunch of reasons and
their DNA is totally different so that
led that that was another mark of of
course the [ __ ] you learn on simulation
I love it
interesting maybe it was two hundred
fifty million you guys I might be off by
a hundred million but you know it was
there was a sudden exterior and it had
no predecessor yeah
I'm whenever I'm asked about the what
animal would you choose to be a question
I answer to I answer both Eagle I want
to fly and I also answer octopus or
squid things I want to be down there and
be the massive ones that are just
observing so he listened so maybe you
came from a different place I definitely
came from a different planet so did
wrong he's also an alien we don't talk
about that place yeah thank you okay so
do you think we're in a computer
simulation no why I don't want to
believe that do you think that a
civilization can become sophistication
ly advanced enough to make a simulation
I love the matrix it's a great it's a
great it is so creative that you know
that story is so creative yeah it's like
one of the most important stories that's
ever been told
I don't I don't want to believe it
however I believe us is basically in our
own Simula our own simulation whether it
is controlled by a nefarious other
intelligence yeah yeah uh-huh okay and
how about our last question what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world love tell us why it it is the
reason for being and it wouldn't what
love turns the entire universe into
something that is amazing every it turns
everything into something that's amazing
I wonder if love is the the energy that
these different civilizations that
spring up as evolution goes on on these
rocks orbiting stars that is love that
force that they need to uncover embody
and develop in order to get past these
Fermi filters these things that stop
civilizations from advancing we're are
you are you following the the the
scientific that the their studies now
about the pituitary gland and DMT and
DMT just maybe the common communicating
element between all life it's a facet
it's a fascinating that that opening
that door is yeah thanks for opening the
door at the end of the show ah
that's such a good door to open yeah so
we are familiar with five Meo DMT we are
familiar with the oneness that it brings
that the transcendence of the ego that
it brings the oneness and the you said
the commonality within the just the
quick cliff notes explained commonality
DMT pituitary gland all all beings can
you cliff notes that for us well I I'm
just I'm just looking at it is is
the human the human species seems to
regard itself as being distinct from it
has it has a peculiar we have it be true
their way of being distinct from nature
we think that we're separate from it yes
and rise above it and have dominion over
mmm
which is probably not the case so think
worsted we're really we're a part of
we're a part of them we're part of all
this and if they're eccentric and dmt if
you've participated in ceremonies and
and had experiences you you have a you
you you have a sense of being a part of
the universe not being distinct from and
DMT is not like is is perhaps the
language within which that transfers
language oh I like that oh we are we are
very excited that you brought that up at
the end of the show and hopefully we can
bring that language to more people and I
think that as that happens that we're
gonna build a better collective world
moving forward John this has been a
[ __ ] pleasure thank you so much this
is life it's super fun we could do this
every day
we'll definitely have to have more of
these powerful conversations unpacking
to the craziness of what happened in the
80s of the Soviet Union shooting down
these MiG's with with with these
strikers and then and also what happened
with cap and trade and how we were in an
environmental crisis and how we were
able to bring that sort of a marketplace
to innovation and then how now token ah
mcc's
and what you're working on with the
Bureau is aiming to do with the
electrical grid and so many other things
a super super exciting and I'm really
pumped to help connect a lot of people
from our network in for you to open up
what you're up to for our network to
also be a part of like
so exciting and let's what about this
fire view what about this DMT of the
language of the universe let's thank you
for being our guest we greatly
appreciate it if you guys found
something useful from today's show make
sure to go create with it that's number
one that's the most important thing
don't just consume the content go create
with it
write about it blog about it video blog
about it talk to other people about a
start a company with it do things like
that
subscribe subscribe join the family join
us by commenting below with your
thoughts we'll feature you on our
Instagram and our Twitter also join us
on patreon we need to make this place
sustainable we need to make these
conversations sustainable we need to
grow this out to be a creative incubator
so we want to bring other YouTube talent
and let them use the production
equipment grow it out house them feed
them etc we want to grow it out so let's
do it together join us on patreon thanks
to Ron Vargas our producing partner
thanks to John we greatly appreciate you
for tuning in and much love peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]